me
shop
[applause]
[music]
akb chun
hahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahaha” It’s
fun,
I didn’t have anything like this in my previous life
Ugh heart shape I
just saw it, I want to stay here forever, I
don’t want to go back to the future
'Cause in the future it's
fine to cut it to the point where there's no one
[music]
I think I'm going to fight The
trigger is the handshake with me
wow!
I was able to go to the bottom after making a brush mark
After all, the professor was the trigger
.
That's right, and you're back.